thirsty today we're gonna be reading
some thirsty YouTube comments our
audience isn't properly hydrated okay
nice let's read some comments how do you
eat my ass
no girl I don't know you like that okay
but man that guy ever
YUM I'd climb that thing like a tree I'm
not like a tree I'm more like a bonsai
well there's really only so much you can
climb tuned in to watch him in the sweat
I might need to check that out to see if
that ended up looking inappropriate and
then can like get it okay so Evan you
can like get it just oh god my pussy's
ready with glasses zach is cute
without he's [ __ ] hot that what she
wrote I can't read this the more I
watched the more moist I become are you
moist Thank You boys zach is bit okay
but daddy two question marks yeah what
do you mean Guardian is my Dominican
daddy
Evan is daddy Zach would be a perfect
father
they forgot the part where he eats naked
would really like to see that experiment
for scientific reasons of course I love
an emphasis on science with our use and
then looking like a hot CEO hello sir
wait are you saying that adorable little
bag has a big penis God eels laughs is
everything why is he eating when he is a
snack
everyone is always so turned on by you
see or eat but I definitely have a crush
on Zach
everyone's turned on by Keith well I can
use that gagging hack for him daddy a
gas attack amigo papi Oh Calado me
important
clicked on this because of the
attractive man and a thumbnail or
whatever gets you into watch just by my
meeting guardian
he's more fine than cocoa powder girl
sex awkwardness makes him five million
times more attractive what well well
well thank you
[Music]
[Music]
zach is the scrawniest piece of [ __ ] I'd
love to break his neck